This is an I-Heart podcast. Guaranteed Human. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hardway with your favorite therapist and host Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to, listen to learn.
the hard way on the IHard radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. I'm on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. Put yourself through some hardships and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO%
on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. When a group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist, they take matters into their own hands.
I vowed. I will be his last target. He is not going to get away with this. He's going to get what he deserves. We always say that trust your girlfriends. Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe, on the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your
podcast. Hello and welcome back to the psychology of your 20s, the podcast where we talk through some of the big changes and transitions of our 20s and what they mean for our psychology. Eggs just farted everyone, so we're going to take a quick five-minute break. Hello and welcome back to the podcast. Thanks for tuning in. We have a very special episode. So today, it's the first ever episode of Girl Talk, because we have three very special guests. Hello, everyone. Hi. Good and talk.
Good and tug. Yeah, I brought on some three special guests, some close friends of mine. We'd like to do a little mini introduction before we get into the Girl Talk. Erin, I'm looking at you. I go first. Of course you do. Hello. My name is Erin.
I've been on the podcast before. What was the episode that you did? I did the 9 to 5 episode a long time ago. Yeah, it was one of our first ever episodes. Guys, you know it's almost a year of the podcast? That's pretty impressive. It's coming up to a year. Really?
What day? On the 5th of June. So I do expect first birthday presents. No, think about it. We have a combined birthday party for me and the podcast. That sounds so sad. No, I love it. I love it. Not so sad.
No. I don't want to have a birthday this year, so we'll make it about the podcast instead. Okay. Because I listen to it so much that I'm practically... And you do receive... I'm an investor. Eric? Okay, wait. For the frequent listeners of the podcast, Erin does actually receive quite a few shoutouts. I do. I do. Yeah. So, now she's in here in the flesh.
And Aaron aside, we have another friend of the podcast, another friend of the show here. Meg. My name's Meg. I have Meg. It's Meg. I have featured on the podcast. It was with Maddie about a Harvard. Oxford. Oh, sorry. Bye-bye.
Wrong answer. You were even on the episode, and you can't even remember the detail. I knew it was Oxford or Harvard. It was also a while ago, though. Yeah, it was a while ago. It was probably nine months ago, I'd say. It was before lockdown in Canberra. Yeah.
Anyway, um, yeah, my name is Meg, and we are all gathered at the coast today. We gathered this there. Thank you, Meg. And our final guest of this very special episode of Girls Talk. Hi, I'm E.J. E.J. A podcast virgin. Podcast virgin.
Yeah, first time. Very excited to break the seal. Break the seal. Sorry. Break the seal. You know, what's a high room? Pop the cherry. Pop the cherry.
Pop the cherry. EJ also hasn't quite realized that on the podcast, do you actually have to sit kind of close to the mic. Sorry. It's, no, it's totally fine. the mic closer to E.J. Well, I was trying to do that. We have already dropped the mic in the bowl of the chips.
I was thinking of... I have a stick. Maybe. Pardon? A stick to, you know. Oh, yeah. Oh, like, tape the phone. Yeah.
We should tape the phone to a stick? Yes. Okay. We'll get to that. It's that's an evolutionary idea. Like a selfie stick, but for the podcast. Yeah. Did that come to mind because we have the fire going in the back?
No, I felt like a microphone. Just pl... But I also thought of a kindling. stick house. Yeah, we could actually probably do that. So, um, welcome EJ. First time, let's all give EJ a warm welcome. Woo! Thanks everyone. Are you excited?
Yeah, I'm keen. A little buzz, but I'm keen. Yeah, we're all a little buzzed, I think. Why did you look at me? I didn't look at it. Um, that, that laughing audio right there gives it away. Don't do this. We're a little bit buzz to do. To our podcast today, I would like you to picture us sweating.
Because we have a beautiful fire created by Gemma. Hey, I did a really good job on that fire. And because of that, we are sweating and we have windows open. We have doors open. We've got bathers on, haven't we? We got bathers on. Meg went a little bit nudie before. I had to get changed.
Into her really sexy underwear. No, I just say, it was really cute. I was admiring it. We're not advertising any brands. No, but what was the brand? No brand. It just has a unicorn. in a chestplate.
It does. And it was gorgeous. So we got the fire going. E.J., maybe you can tell the listeners, why are we all gathered here today? We all live in different cities. So what has made it that we're all here today? We really needed a break.
We really needed a vacation. So we all came together. And that's why we're at the coast. So we're at the coast, yeah. Which coast? Near Jarvis Bay? Yes. Yeah.
Milton. Milton? Yeah, we're Milton. And how did this all... Someone didn't put their phone on silent. Didn't someone on this side? Give me shit having my phone silent. Oh, I did.
Okay, for context, again, EJ lost her phone about five times today. One of these times she left her phone on top of the car in a petrol station and the car was moving. Yeah, so basically we all needed a break and we decided that we should go to the coast. Yeah. Yeah. So me and E.J.
drove down from Sydney. Aaron drove from Canberra. We'll get to that. And Meg, what did you drive from? From Swift's Creek. Swift's Creek. In Victoria. Yes, exactly.
Thank you. Not Swiss as in the country. Swiss Army now? Yeah. No, yes. Drove from there yesterday. And we all got here and we've had a really lovely day. What would we say?
Yeah, it's beautiful. Most beautiful weather. We did have an incident with the car. Oh, yes. Would anyone like to explain what happened there? Erin. Erin, what happened with my car? And of course it was, I'm just going to, wait, just quickly,
it was my car because I do not take care of my car. Gemma had not pumped her ties up since December. We are now in May. Six months. Six months. Dear listener, Um, and yes, so the tires were not doing well. Hopefully they're not punctured.
I don't think they're punctured. I just don't think you pumped them up. Well, this random guy, we were trying to go to this op shop and it was closed. Sadly. Unfortunately. And we were in this, what would you describe it as, EJ? The $2 shop next to the op shop. Yeah.
It was a true. We were like, oh my God, we have temporary tattoos. Oh, I've got a temporary tattoos. Okay, wait, wait. Sorry. Sorry. I don't get into it. A podcast.
You have a podcast. You have podcast. I think maybe we should finish this. Guys, Erin almost literally ran... I do. I want to commit. A hyperfixation needs to be on one... No, to the podcast. Oh, to the...
Oh, to the podcast. Oh, wait, wait. So, we basically... Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait. So we... Let's just do a little bit of a refresh year. We went... We tried to go to this Vinnie's.
We ended up going there. It was closed. So we went to this $2 shop and E.J. has bought temporary tattoos. Erin literally just leaped out of her seat, then, to go and do them. They're so cute. They are really cute, but we're also literally recording right now.
I thought it could be a fun side activity. But the podcast listeners can't play along. They just have to listen to us, give each other temporary. Go to a $2 tattoo tattoo. To do a $2 shop, finds him really cute temporary tattoos and buy a sweater handmade by the lady who runs a shop. Because she's a really good crochet artist. Yeah, well, so basically this lady was really nice,
and she was, like, hand crocheted all these sweaters. and this is a real sidebar but we were in this store and then this random guy came up to me and was like, how would you was just, what did he say? Do you remember? Excuse me.
Your left hand tires. Right hand. No, no, but he said left hand and then he corrected himself. And then he said, oh, I meant the right hand tire is a bit flat and then Gemma went out to inspect it.
I did go out to inspect it. And I had like a weird like crochet bikini top on. But like the lady was like you should try it on. And then this man came in was like your tires deflated and I was like, oh. Oh good. But he was like your tires, it looks like you should get that checked out. And we were like in the middle of but fuck nowhere. Like this is like some tiny town.
Walla, Walla, Walah. It's Kalala Bay, everyone. We were in Kalala Bay, dear listener. We were in Kalala Bay, dear listener. We were in Kalala Bay. Lalibay and it was literally like Vinnie's chicken shop There was an RGA there
I guess and then there was this weird $2 store What did you know? Before Teranova anyway Sorry, sidetracked Everyone is not being great Erin! I want to hear about Meg's
Terranova experience I don't know how did I have it? Yeah, I've told you about it I just didn't realize that was where it was You're gonna say No, okay Maybe we'll cut that bit out I don't think we're going to
this is an authentic episode and we're being highly authentic here. It's called Girl Talk, babe. This is what girls do. We talk. We talk. And we paint our mouths and we get temporary tattoos and buffer flies. I mean, Erin is like really on a scat moment right here. She's like, you cannot keep focus.
I've had the flu all weekend, by the way, everybody. And I'm sweating because I don't know whether it's the pot or don't know where this is hot. I'm sweating. It's really hot. It's very warm. So maybe we should move on to this question that we had. How are we all doing? Aaron, are you...
I think I've done a good job of explaining how I'm going. I've got the flu. I've got the terrible camera flu. And what's it be? Somebody said... Oh, there's like this name for it that somebody used the other day.
Super flu. Super flu. No, it was like... Influenza A. I'm not. Swine flu. No, it was like this horrible like...
No, Tuesday flu sentence that was like... Swin flu. It's the like... It's the like... Um, Anyway, I have the flu and I'm being a little baby about it. I don't know if I haven't been coping very well.
But I also haven't been feeling very well. It's worse than COVID. 110%. So, yeah. Wait, I thought of a joke. Yeah. Swine flu. I can't.
Swine flu walked so coronavirus could run. My God. I just totally laughed. I thought that was so funny. I mean, I don't know. I think COVID humor is still, unfortunately. quite more. Sorry, we've got to
basically try to put, we're in this little cabin and I sit, we put this fire on and it's so hot. And it's right opposite to where we're sitting. Like we're sitting very close. Yeah, it's like burning us. It's very warm. It died. It's really fucking hot.
Oh, no, and now we've broken it. Pull. Oh, there you go. Oh, no, no, other way, other way. There you go. Meg has broken the fireplace. And our Airbnb host is this old lady. The window is wide open.
Oh. Hi. But she's like this old grandma and she's really, really sweet. She's really, really sweet. The house is like 300 meters from where we are sitting. Yeah. It's quite close. And they're chicken.
There's a rooster. It's sexually assaulting. Every single fucking hen out there. I actually was so traumatized today. Don't even start me. How am I going? not very well. Like, E.J.
You're up. Traumatized because we have these, basically at this Airbnb, there are all these chickens. There are all these chickens. There are all these chickens that are running around. And there's this one, free range. Very cute, but they're like,
try and eat out pancakes. And then there's this one rooster and it's like fully going at it with all the chickens. Waking us up. Waking us up firstly. At 5 a.m. 5 a.m. With disgusting crow.
Yeah. And um... How that girl, Aaron? Yeah, what was that? Yeah, that wasn't great. So EJ is slightly traumatised. Meg, how are you going? Um, I'm actually doing great.
I am a bit, I think, not low, but a bit tired. I think maybe I did get the flu shot yesterday. Or I could you be just tired from the driving? But apart from that, I'm feeling good. They do six hours to be here with us. But I'm here now for five days. Anyway Wait, for five days
No, around the East South Wales Oh, you're coming back to Canberra Yeah And how are you, Jenna? Uh I'm doing great guys I'm fine I've been better, I've been worse
I think I'm a bit I've had a few glasses of the line Do I really want to divulge all my secrets? No, that's here Probably not But we did make Meg explain How dogs have sex On the podcast
People need to know yeah yeah fine lots of people buy puppies so they've got to know how it's been conceived oh that's true oh my god I thought that was I think that's absolutely hilarious but I think I'm doing I'm doing okay I'm like bit lonely bit sad at the moment are you with us yeah and so I'm feeling really the chip ball hit again if you're wearing headphones I'm sorry sorry but anyway so I'm doing well Erin's doing okay she's sick EJ's been traumatized by the chickens having sex. Meg is good.
Satisfactory. Satisfactory. A bit tired. A bit tired because she got the flu shot. Yeah. I feel like that's a great introduction. Yeah. That's a really good introduction.
So the plan with these chit-chat episodes, this one being the first, is a much more unstructured kind of conversation amongst friends. What do we think about this? Erin, any ideas? Meg, how do you feel? I don't mind it, but I just think they do need a little bit of structure, otherwise it just drags on. Yeah.
Yeah. We have structure. Yeah, so small tangent, that may only not have already been recorded and lost to the bowels of time. The boughs of time. Bows of EJ. Yeah, guys, we had to take a quick break because EJ has to go outside and fart. I'm sorry.
The Bows of E.J. Is the fact that Jack, my partner, doesn't like chit-chat podcast, and you don't either, Jem. I know this is a fact because I've tried to get you to listen to them before now, and you get so bored of the conversation, you skip them all. So he doesn't like it because he wants to, like, be a part of the conversation, so he doesn't like the fact that he's listening to their conversation, and he's not part of it, and he doesn't know the people. who are talking. So I find the podcast really fun to listen to when I know the people that
are chit-chatting because I know their story and I know their background. But, um, so if you don't know us, you're feeling, so if you don't know us, it's probably not that entertaining. But to solve that, we're pretty funny. We're pretty funny. And also, it's a bouts of PJ. The bowels of EJ is particularly. Um, we're pretty funny. And also it's going to be structured. So we will be answering interesting questions about life. It will not just be us rambling because I listened to a terrible one the other day. Mine. My podcast.
No, not yours. Oh my God. I would never say such a thing about psychology of your 20s. Oh, that's my podcast. That was a sort of what it was called. No, because I, as you know, I'm a devout listener. But I listen, yeah, I listened to one the other day and people just talking about, like, their weekends and how they felt about, like, some girl that they knew.
And I was like, can we not do this, please? How do we feel about E. E.J. I love that. I love a good shit. You love it. I love a good chit-chat. Interesting.
I listened to a 20-minute podcast about why they didn't like Zara. And I-that's-throft doing that. Because that's, like, actually something of substance. No, because, no, because it was about, like, midlife crisis. And then they spent 20 minutes talking about going into Zara and how they didn't like how it looked like. Oh, my God. And I really enjoyed that. I thought I'm quite their beauty.
Are you talking about the recent goes-out-s-out-saying podcast? Oh, my God, yeah. Yeah, I literally listen. I need to shout out. Not to shout out. I'm not even, I know. I know that. I listened to that episode
I loved that. I like, literally like two days ago. Excuse me. Anyway. Please do not promote other podcasts on my podcast. Do not go and watch, listen to that podcast. We're not. What was it again?
The podcast name is goes about same. Why would you? Erin. She wanted to know. I think you could tell a later. That was a true question. I thought it was a genuine question. Bop-bar, off the podcast.
Failed. Banished. Canceled. Go far outside and. Go sit outside and eat those spots. Then, farmed. And we just...
Everyone's giving me shit for a spot outside. We just ate sausages, so you know it's not smelling very good. This episode is more for us, and it's more for us being able to look back in the future in five years' time. Back of this cabin. And back into this cabin with the fucking hot fireplace. When you have a million subscribers.
When I have a million subscribers. And also there's... So the fireplace, the cock, the big old roost up, that abuses the hens and makes farts. E.J. Farts. And E.J. Farts, but we can think back on it fondly. So, oh, my God. So, I guess that's a really good segue.
All right. Back on track. Back on track. So, five years time. Love it. It's a bit of a chop. No, I can love this. I love this. No, I just thought we were going to have a question before we got to the five years' part of question.
Okay, well, what do you think you're going to be in two years' time? No, that's worse. Yeah, five years. We'll stick to the question. So five years' time. Where do you think we're going to be in five years time? We're having an amazing weekend. Do you think we're going to be doing this in five years?
Where are we going to be? Individually or as a group? Individually. Oh, okay, so I had like a whole 10-year plan at uni. I knew exactly where I was going to be. at like 32 and then I had a five year plan. I think it's still the go. Really?
I love to do that. Obviously it really changed because I graduated in 2020 and I wanted to like travel for a year after uni. But like obviously I didn't because of COVID. So I've ended up jumping into my career, you know? So I've kind of got this idea of doing two and a half years of just like working, earning money. And then I'm going to drop everything and move to Ireland and then become a bartender.
And like I was telling you guys today, and I just want to travel, learn a language. And there's like this like... Irish. Yeah. And I just want to do that for like two and a half years. Gaelic. Gaelic.
Sorry. Irish is a language? No, but they say Gaelic, I think. The language is Gaelic in Ireland. So you're going to learn Gaelic? Oh, I didn't anticipate anything about that. French. It's quite hard actually.
But I was also thinking I'm maybe going to like Spain and teaching like English for like three months or something. That's a good idea. I just want to do something, you know? Gaelic. It's Gaelic. That's not Scotland. I thought that was Welsh. Welsh is different again.
I think there's Scottish Gaelic and Irish Gaelic. Well, maybe you just learned the language that is native to the Irish people. Yeah. And it could be Gaelic and it could be Welsh. We don't know. Yeah. It's definitely not Welsh. It could be Irish.
Yeah. EJ's five your plan sounds very beautiful. Let's not undermine it. Whoa, I didn't anticipate that. I don't know. Well, I didn't mean that. No, I'm like very like, I've loved thinking about my job and getting money and thinking about where I want to go. But I'm also like, I feel like there's an element to me that hasn't been fulfilled because of COVID.
And so I'm very content with just separating my professional career and my life. And especially when I'm young and in my 20s, I'm going to like create that future for me. So like I really, I'm happy where I am in my job. I'm happy with all that. But like, I'm ready to kind of just say, goodbye and then go overseas meet more people you know yeah yeah you know that's like and what when do you think that's going to happen in the next two years yeah 100% I'm like aiming for like September next year to be like moved overseas what yeah I mean it might not happen
yeah so like but like manifesting it I hope I would like I've had a lot of bills recently though so my savings are going yeah you can always save you can always save yeah exactly it's a very romantic view but I've always I'm very optimistic I'm very like yeah I'm ready to do it you know they said 2023 didn't they yeah right at the side of COVID exactly actually they said they said 2023 was the time international like kind of travel would happen again it's more like normal yeah in quotation marks normalised like we're still internationally traveling but it's like still a bit well you guys are going to Bali what and you're going to Europe I'm going to Europe yeah I think I'm going to be Vegas going
Meg's going to... To Bali with us. We're trying to convince her. Meg's going to Townsville. That's pretty much... Innesvale. Innesvale. Pretty much international.
Yeah. From Swift's Creek. Yes. It takes just as much time to drive to Inesvale as it does to find... I was going to say it's probably similar to travel. Probably. Probably more expensive. Probably more expensive to even fly to Inisfil.
Geez. Now, how much? Much cheaper. Yeah. Yeah. Wow. $500. $500.
It's more. But this is like Gemma drove like 12 hours to Queensland and then the flights to Brisbane was like $80. No, but the flights to Brisbane are... From Sydney. From Sydney, the flights to Brisbane are really cheap. From camera, they're really expensive. But it's the journey, it's not the destination. And I had a great...
Well, okay, my journey involved me getting a hit and run. So, remember, when someone knocked my window off my mirror off my car and I have to pay $300. I think that's an absolutely magical dream, E, James. Thank you. at you, Malia and speak to you in Gaelic. In my head, in my head, this is very, like, not to put dreams onto you guys, but in my head,
Gemma's going to be in the UK doing her masters. She's going to be, Meg's going to be doing a tour around Europe, and then Erin's going to be living in, like, with you. Yeah, exactly. I'm a, sorry, we're going to be, we're going to be,
we're going to be, we will be living together. We will be roommates above a bar in Ireland. Oh, oh, you just like your boyfriend. Jack and Josh? Should they come up? I mean, if they want to come to come up. I'd like, Jack definitely would. I'm speaking.
Well, I think Josh would. Josh would. I mean, I hope so. If you're listening to this, you're probably not, but you guys are going to become best friends. We're planning it in our heads. Is that part of the five-year plan? This is public.
This is public. This is public. This is part of the five-year plan. Yeah. We are going to go and live in a, what, do we want, like a three-bedroom house? Three-bedroom. Yeah, three-bedroom. Yeah, because then we're going to get a little.
And May can come. We can show a bed. Megan Jeff can come visit us and then we can like go and do whatever jobies we do in Ireland. Exactly. I'd live in Ireland. I'd love to live in Ireland. Okay, so basically Aaron has jumped on the band right. E.J.'s dream.
No, but it's a great dream. And we do great living together. I'm sweating my tits off. I'm sorry. It's very warm. E.J. and I have previously lived together just to the listener knows. So we know what each other's living style is like. We're very compatible housemates.
I would say E.J. How do you feel? She doesn't like my smoothies in the morning Oh god, actually yeah, that's true I don't do smoothies in the morning because I'm worried I'm going to wake up the boys Because I go to my housemates I make just found a chip Let's move that away
But I go to bed at like 11 And then wake up at like 6 or 7 That's what EJ used to do And then she used to put the smoothie blender on at 6am And I would be very, very upset And you all know I'm already not a morning person Oh my God This morning we all
went to the beach and Aaron stayed in bed. Sorry. And then she was like, you guys were talking all more. And she had three against one as well. And she had ear plugs in. I can still hear you. It was ridiculous. It sounds like a new problem.
It does actually. It was a big problem. To be completely fair. You guys were all having a lovely chart. We were having cuddles. Oh. And you never give us cuddles. That's because I've got the flow.
I don't care. Influenza A, babe. So Meg, what is your final? year plan. Oh. Erin has already just jumps on the bandwagon of EJ's.
You don't get any more safe. My dreams are reduced to jumping on the bandwagon of EJ's dreams and nothing else. So Meg, what's your five-year plan? Look, to be honest, I don't really know
what I'm doing at the moment. You know, I don't have a certain thing I want to do. But I'm saying that, travel is definitely something I've missed out on too, like EJ said. So definitely going overseas,
living over there or travelling both for a bit. Definitely Asia. Asia. Like Central Asia. Yeah. That's why you should come to Bali. Yes. Which is not one of the Central Asia?
No. No. But it's travel. Maybe, yes. And then... What about your three-month plan? Because you've got some big plans. Oh, yes.
I am finishing my job in two weeks in Swiss Creek. And I'm going up to Queensland to do some other seasonal work. which is yet to be decided. TBA. TBA and what I'm doing, but it'll probably be outdoor work. Yeah. A bit of group-picking.
Yeah, something like that. Yeah, so that's exciting and be of a change. That's where me and Erin are from. Good news. Boo-ya, baby. I will visit your hometown. You will visit my hometown. Don't visit Brisbane.
Brisbane's not worth going to. Don't say that one was his dunnings from there. I was going to visit. Again, truly not really. worth. People like visiting Brisbane as tourists. I'm sorry, my hometown is fucking beautiful. Yeah. You can visit it.
I've never been to Brisbane. Corrumban is beautiful. Don't go to Brisbane. Go to Corrumban. I will. I will. Small town, baby. Anyhow. But in five years' time, where are you living, Meg?
Probably overseas. I might be close to Ireland. No, but definitely overseas. Probably I want to go to Canada next. year maybe yeah oh that would be fun that incredible overseas or doing something maybe outdoorsy or with you know hands-on I'm not sure yeah you do um seasonal firefighting
in Canada potentially but next year oh not seasonal firefighting well you can do seasonal firefighting but it's like it's a really interesting wait just canadian Canada do they pay you um does Canada pay you to plant trees yeah but it's actually like one of the most work like it's it's really interesting job because it pays really well and you like it's outdoors and you kind of go and living these like little like camps for like months of a time but it's actually really really really hard because you get paid per tree that's like australia's how much you get per tree like 20 cents yeah so you got to plant a lot of trees yeah but once you get going you get like the body gets used to it my head first i'm
my head for somebody like pictureing a giant plant yeah i can plan a tree in like oh no you should watch these like i went through a phase when i was living in counter on exchange where I was like, I'm going to become a tree planter, because I met this person who was like, yeah, I was a tree planter and I'm going back. I was like, oh, that's so interesting. And, um, but I watch these YouTube blogs and, like, people get like, like, your body, like, does not recover. Like, the shorter you are, the better because you're closer to the ground. Yeah, yeah. That's very true.
What if you're a midget? It's perfect for you because you don't have to bend down. You also have to, okay, think about this. You've got to carry, like, all the stuff you need for tree planting so that you've got, like, and then, like, you need water. And then, like, you need water. And then they just dump you in the middle of a paddard. all day and then you just got like dig holes and plant trees all day and you did nothing else and do they go around and count the trees that you pile no they count how many
trees are in your backpack yeah yeah but then like I saw these things of people who'd like big digging trees and they'd hit like a hornet's nest and then they get like bitten on their face by like all these like bees that's like a fucking hungry game and then there's like bears yeah this sounds terrible yeah but they can pay really well because like you work for like three months and you own like quite a significant amount money and you make friends and quite a lot of young people do it and you get eaten by a bear well I didn't say a vlog of somebody getting eaten by bear but it's certainly a hazard Aaron so that's your five-year goal is it no absolutely to be eaten by a bear in Canada planning
pine trees yes well and it's an interesting thing because I think no just quickly I think they plant the trees for forestry so they plant them so they grow and then they're cutting down again so it's not even like fun tree regeneration oh yeah like it's like native and stuff yeah that's a lot in Australia too. So it's commercial. It's commercial. Oh, that sounds fucked. Why do I do that?
And you think that a machine can do it in this day and age? Maybe so. It's a bit rough. Yeah, and I think so kind of remote like that's actually. You're like helicopter drops. But think about this,
because the tree, it would plant it in the front and then it would probably run it over. Just think about, so the tree, like, think about a machine and think about like, no. How do you think they plant crops? I don't know. With seeds.
It's seeds. In the back. back. Oh, and then they go in the front and I was like, why would you do that? Because then you're going to run over the trees. I do not work with my hands. It's very obvious. I do not have a
working woman's job. I work in an office. I like that. Working woman's job. Yeah. I'm just a little office bitch. A little corporate bitch. Yeah. So your five-year plan is involving travel. Well, theoretically, but I
like to pry myself on the fact that I don't have five-year plan. No, I was literally about to say this. Like, I was like, I was like, I talk a lot about having plans, but like, especially with what COVID's taught me, it's like good to not have a plan. It's good to, like, have this, like, optimism, you know? Yeah. Yeah. I think I'm the same, although I'm going to be honest, I have a pretty, pretty intense five-year plan. Yeah. I think five-year, like, I'm somebody in general, just quickly. Yeah. Because I feel quite strongly about this topic. Great. That's what we want on the podcast. I'm somebody who, like, I never made goals. I'm somebody who, like, I never made goals ever like even when I was at school and they're like you got to make a goal I was like
I don't want to make a goal because it's just going to lead to disappointment and a fear of failure that's less great so because of fear of failure I never wanted to do you did you ever have like sorry to go off try but did you ever like academic like validation like did you ever like in high school like get an assignment and you're like I want top grade uh yeah of course is that not similar that's a goal that's a goal but like I would never make a goal by myself like I would never do a goal myself. I'd just be like, oh, I'm going to get this assignment and I'm going to do well because I do well. Oh, you, okay. The assignment was already set. Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah. So it's like somebody set to me. A society told you that life goals are more abstract. Life goals are very
abstract. They're not set for you. Because there's multiple paths as well. Like a school assignment, you don't have multiple paths. Yeah. But life, you have many multiple paths. It's what you can do and what you can pick and there's like an intense amount of variables and it's very scary. And so I, I... This is true. You just had three glasses of wine. She's feeling as... Life is beautiful.
So gorgeous. But yeah, so I don't make goals because I don't like goals and they make me stressed. Fair enough. Yeah, I think there can be a healthy balance in it. This is very true. Anyway, what's your one? You've got... I'm enjoying this.
Well, yeah, no. Because you've got the opposite of what Aaron is. Oh, yeah, absolutely. But I just think it's quite restrictive as well because I think if you make a goal... But it's not restrictive. It's just like... Because the goals are like... No, no, no, but I mean that like my goals are just goals
and my life is created around them. Yeah, it's good to have a direction, I guess. Well, it's just like, I want to be... But, hey, it's not like, my goals are a lot more. I think my goals are a lot more. They're not like, I need to be living in a house with my partner and have three children and I would like a dog and its name would be penny. Like, it's more like, I know that in two years I want to be doing my master's in a living.
Because I think a lot of people make those goals that you were talking about in the first instance. So it's like, I need a house and pets and a child. And I think that's why a lot of people, like, for example, when they can't have kids, they get really disappointed because their whole life has been about this one goal and fulfilling this one role. Yeah. Whereas mine is like, also it's too. Which we could go on about for a mom's time. We can probably jump into that in a later day.
Yeah. Whereas my goal is like, I know that in two years I want to be in London, studying my master's. Yeah. That's not a constrictive goal. Totally, totally. Yeah, that's like I want to be, I know I want to be overseas next year, but I, like, I did say September. But, like, I was, I know in the foreseeable future, I would love to be overseas, wherever that is, you know? Yeah.
It's a very interesting thing. Yeah. See, I think because I've had so many things happen in life that have happened purely by chance. And I think, as well, propelled somewhat by COVID, where I've made. a big life plan I was like so ready to do all these things after exchange and go travelling and then none of that could happen I was like well that's the last time I ever make a goal because that didn't happen and it was so disappointing and very upsetting and like a huge waste of like energy even getting myself to that point
only to have the rug pulled from underneath me I think it's like I think it's good to have that like realistic like perspective of it but I also I can't see where jam is coming from I really that can be such a happy balance and I think that a lot of it has to do with like as well my general life mindset is a very negative one. Yes, we've talked about this before. We've talked about this before. But also, Aaron, I don't have a partner. Yeah.
I don't have anything tying me anywhere. Yeah. But like I have a partner and I, and he is extremely aware of like my boundaries in the sense where I have like gone into that and it's been like, I want to be overseas. I want to be doing this and these are things I want to achieve in my life. Do you think long distance helps with that? I think so.
I think he's really been open-minded to my perspective. because I also think I don't want him to be restricted. His goal setting, I don't want his life to just revolve around me. So in my head, I'm like, I want to be overseas with consideration that maybe he wants to join me. But if he doesn't want me, doesn't want to, like, we can work through that. You know what I mean? I do. Honestly, it's been interesting because I've been having, like, a real, like, I love, the thing is, I haven't really met Meg's partner.
But I've met, but wait, wait, wait, wait. I've met Jack, obviously. I've met Aaron's partner. I know Aaron and EJ's partners quite well, I would say. And I feel like, and all of my friends at the moment have boyfriends and partners. But that's one thing. And I've been feeling like kind of sad about it because like obviously I went through a breakup at the start of the year. It like completely destroyed me.
We've talked about it a lot. But moving onwards. Moving onwards. Fuck him. But the thing is it's like I have been like kind of in a weird headspace about it recently. And then I'm like, actually, there are some pretty. amazing upsides to it. For example, if tomorrow I decided, oh, like, I want to move to London. Yeah. You can do that. I could literally do it. Yeah. And also my work is so great that I could do it
as well. Like, it's a beautiful thing. I had a really interesting conversation with Jack the other day. I could also move to Toronto. Sorry, go. Sorry. Oh, Jesus. Choice of. I'm not going to move to fucking Toronto. Yeah. You know how my seasonal depression be. Um, I had a really interesting conversation with Jack the other day about this as a concept. because like when you're with somebody I was like at the end of the day you've got to prioritise yourself number one baby
so whatever you want to do like even if that involves not having me around at the end of the day it's about you and about your life and don't constrain your life yeah to suit the relationship you're in because at the end of the day all you have is yourself Megan and I were talking about this yes we were literally an hour ago
but like I also think makes a good example and says she's still going to Queensland and has a partner people always ask me Are you going with Takama? No, I'm not. Exactly, it's not coming. You're creating my own reality. Yeah.
Is that hard? You know? No, I've always planned to go by myself. Yeah. It's my plan. Yeah. Good on you. Because you had a goal.
Yeah. A goal, and it's a goal that is useful. Mm-hmm. But back to this, I think in five years' time, I would like to, A, I'm going to say this, I would like to have not been in a relationship in that period. Yeah. I am pretty set on staying single with a capital S for the next five years. I would like to have a lot of new friends.
Okay. I would like to be doing. No, no, no. I'll just be showing myself out. But I would like, and then I... That's the natural. Yeah, but I would like to have a continue... Like, obviously, you guys aren't people I'm letting go of,
and I'd like to live somewhere other than Australia. Although I am a big Sydney fan at the moment. You just move there. I'm obsessed with Sydney. E.J. Can't say the same, but... Made to me. I've never liked to live.
So Meg is living in a pretty small country town. Yes, I am. And we went to this bar yesterday. Oh, it was overwhelming. Yeah, what was your... A bar in Milton. Bar in Milton, New South Wales. So not particular most pump in place.
There were... To be fair, it was different. It was a Mexican bar. Well, a Mexican bar. It was a bit of a weird Australasian fusion. Okay, Austro-Mexican. Austro-Mexican. A whole new cuisine.
Austro-Mexican. And there was just so many people there and they kept staring at me but they weren't it's just because you haven't... You haven't been around large amounts people.
You haven't been around people. Yeah, and then I was then we're talking about Sydney and Canberra even and I get very overwhelmed because there's so many people. Imagine, okay imagine Meg in Sydney with us. E.J. You'd be pretty sure us.
Meg oddly though. I remember when we went to Melbourne and weren't you still living you were living in Bombol at that stage and you coped okay in Melbourne But that might be a familiar stage. I think actually you might be right
because I was not okay in Melbourne I know, I know, because that was like the city I knew. Yeah, you're pretty familiar with it but yeah, Sydney you're less familiar with? I mean there a couple times. Yes, sweet. Yeah, very, very true. I feel like you have really really struggled.
Here's the thing about Sydney though that I've been really interested. I don't know if you feel the same, E.J. I feel so ugly. Oh my God. This is... What a great. Yeah.
No, but I feel... No, this is... No, no, I can... I can agree with her. I can agree with her. There is a different... There's a subculture of beauty that has been... It's a different standard.
It's a quickly. It's not a subculture of beauty. It's a subculture of people with a lot of disposable income and very rich parents. So what are they... What are they using for? So there's like... Lip fill is beautiful. Bitch. Basically, I want to get lip fillers.
My hair line. So, no, I was talking to, I was talking to my housemates the other day about this. I don't know what it is. I'm going to blame it all on the guy I was seeing at the start of the year for absolutely destroying my self-confidence. Can I get a what-what? What-what? Yeah, thank you. Silence from everybody else. No.
I started and then it was too late. Yes. But I don't know what it is, but when I moved to Sydney, I was like, wow. I'm so ugly, but also just like my personal circumstances where I was like, I'm unlovable. And I was like, I should get lip fillers. And then I was get drunk the other night and I was telling my housemates about it. And I was like, what do you? And I was going to book an appointment.
And it was like, have you seen, okay. I googled it. I was, also I'm scared of injections. I was going to say, I, if you ever want to scare yourself out of getting lip fillers, watch the Jeffrey Star video where he gets his lip fillers removed because they were like, went bad and like collagulated in his lips and he films everything. Wait what? Okay, so he got these like really bad.
This is when, okay, I've got to stop from the beginning. Jeffrey Starr, as people know, is very problematic. I want to assure you that I no longer watch Jeffrey Starr. And if you, but if you did, who cares? Well, I don't want to get cancelled. Council, not cancel. That's our phrase on the show. Council, not cancel.
But Jeffrey Starr is really problematic. But basically he filled his lip filler like removal. So he had like plastic surgery but he got it like done back in the day when they weren't really like a big mainstream thing. And they just did them really, really wrong. And they like put something in it that got like stuck in his lip. So he had like a lump in his lip. Was it plastic? It was like yeah, some kind of plastic.
And it didn't like dissolve. And then he had to get them like professionally removed. and like he filmed the whole process of getting removed and I was like I just like I can't I cannot think of anything worse I'd still get it you should watch it and I know I watched it like 14 and I got like mentally scarred by it so yeah recommendation if anybody's on the fence go watch that video I don't even know what's cool now what do you think about it I I've I've thought about that we're in Bombala my old housemate we were talking about it quite seriously yeah about getting it but then I I was pretty like for it but then
I didn't realize you have to get them every like two years. So that's, that's a lot of money every two years. But maybe by the time, you know, by the time when 24, we won't care as much. No, no, that's the thing. Well, same. I was like, I want to get them now because I want the,
I mean, my early 20s, that's when you look the best, surely. Yeah. I just want to look really hot. I think I get worried that you get used to the look of them and then you get, like, stuck in the addictive loop of spending money on them. Well, that's moving my eyebrows. Yeah.
So, just quickly, E.J., but I got my eyebrow, because I, I've been on like this whole like weird self-love, self-confidence journey. And I started getting my eyebrows done and like, what is it called? Tinged. Tinted and done and now I'm addicted. Yeah, because you don't get used to how you look. I spend $50 a month on getting my eyelashes and my eyebrows tinted, which I never thought I would be that person.
Yeah. Even nails. That person is really a thing. Yeah. But E.J, what do you think? So I have this like really back and forth relationship about like, like, cosmetic surgery where it was like so similarly with like like jama i had this like experience with an ex where he's he pointed out that i had really thin a thin upper lip oh it's disgusting
i yeah and i got really like insecure about it i was quite young i was just turned 18 sort of thing and what was his name zip zip No calling it. Anyway, I was quite horrible. It was zip, though. And I was quite, like, I became very, like, innately aware of it. And it was something like I would, like, take photos and they were like, oh, my God, I don't know, I'm up in the lip. And I would consider, like, getting, like, lip fillers.
But I'd always see, like, people on television or people in real life, and it just, either they had overdone it or this kind of stuff. But then I started thinking about it, like, if you feel beautiful and you feel content with your decision and confident in your, decision, like, go ahead, but as long as you're aware of, like, the health precautions. Yeah. But then you start to think, sorry to get really met of here, but it's like, you start thinking about, like, the cosmetic culture and you start thinking of plastic, like, surgery culture. Is it done for, right men benefits of women's insecurities? Exactly. And it's like, what is...
Where does the money go? Exactly. And you think, like, what is beauty? It's, like, especially in Western culture, it is like post-colonial beauty of like blue eyes blonde hair it's like yeah you know what I mean that's yeah so many cultures are like it's people like aren't gonna remember you like at your funeral for like your lit tillers they're gonna remember you feel like how kind you wear yeah but I also it's a very interesting thing for me so I'm interested in getting so I think the lip filler thing and the cheek filler thing because that's another thing I'm concerned yeah I'm For yourself?
But you guys, I think you guys all know, like, the last three months have been hard because I just felt so low. Because this person, like, completely, like, just like, are you doing it for, like, like, I'm not doing it to, like, impress them. I'm not doing it to feel more attractive. Yeah. The only reason I'm doing it is because I'm like, if I had this done, I would actually feel confident enough. Yeah. To be myself. Well, yeah.
Because I feel like my external would match my internal. Yeah. But I don't know. That's really interesting though because sometimes I think that that's a bit like the whole concept of like if I buy this dress I will finally be satisfied and never want a black dress that is short and I can wear out again. It's like this culture of wanting. There's a culture of wanting. There's a really, um, Ruby Sparks has a really good book about this. Um, I can't remember what the book's called.
Yeah. But it's blue. It's got a blue cover. And it's about this concept where like when she was like in the pits of despair basically, um, a stepy of wing would call it. On EG&I's favorite. The Pits of Despair. No, joking because this podcast is a favorite. The Pits of Despair, she went through a phase where she was like,
if I get six cushions that are perfect for the couch, I will finally be good. I will finally be happy. And she spent months searching for these perfect cushions for her couch that fitted the aesthetic of her whole house. And it was going to be perfect. And she was like, yeah, that like it was never going to happen because as soon as you get those cushions, you want more. But it's this concept where she was, like, addicted to, like, find, this thing and it's actually like it's a like a psychological thing
obviously because my exercise is a little bit different but it's a psychological thing this like hunter and gathering instinct which is why like when we go shopping we feel really good for like 10 seconds and then like two weeks later we're like oh I forgot I bought that but it's actually activates the like part of your brain that has the hunter gather a
complex it's like when I gather things for my tribe my tribe will love me but I think for me personally it's like and I really do see that I think that like and I would say you know pretty well I have a very addictive personality. Goes about saying. But that's why I think
that it's like for me right now I'm like okay, if I, it's literally plastic surgery. Yeah. But it just shows how like deeply, I think it's like much more psychological. Yeah. I'm so injured psychologically by this relationship and I'm like I, if I just
physically change my appearance so this person couldn't recognize me anymore until I could feel like myself so I could feel physically attractive. If I fundamentally change some aspect of how I looked, I finally feel like I am not, like, beholden to how this person sawed me. Yeah. Which is why self-acceptance is a good thing.
I've been trying that. It's not working. It doesn't do it. I think I wanted today. Because, like, I feel like, obviously, like, we're not the same person, but, like, I feel like I can relate to a level with the experience about, like, lips and stuff with Gemma. Like, I've had this whole thing.
like I've thought about it. I haven't gone ahead with it because I know where I'm, like, where I'm standing from is a place to please them and to please this like male gaze. But then there is that other end of it. And sorry to bring this up again. But I really want to get my hairline tattooed. But that is like for me. Yeah.
Like I know that's for me. It's for me. You know? Like I'm not dating. Like there's no one I'm trying to impress. I'm not trying to get laid. I'm not trying to date. I literally just feel like it would just like allow me.
be more like myself. Isn't it so interesting, though, that women are at this stage where it's like to feel like myself, I fundamentally have to spend a lot of money on changing a so massive for myself. And also, what is beauty? But also, like, nothing wrong with, like, past...
You don't just support me no matter what. Totally. And I also think that at the end of the day, like, no shame. Like, go get whatever you want done, go for it. Like... But why did you want to get them make? Well, I... I just didn't like my lips. I was like, oh, I just, you know.
Probably because I've seen like big lips and like, oh, that, you know, that looks nice. Yeah. It looks so beautiful. Yeah, but like, you know, it's just like. No, but yeah, it is. You know, you see, I'm like, oh, you know, it's just that the ideal of beauty or whatever. Like, you know, the models or whatever. Not really, the models, but just like people, you know.
Yeah, it's a current beauty standard. Yeah, it's a current beauty standard. Like the Kardashians plucked what they wanted from like. Different cultures. Different cultures around the world. And then made that mainstream and made that consumable. and now that's like what we all are all expected to look like because women obviously all have to look at the same way.
Yes. According to whatever trends are currently happening because God forbid we are a diverse, unique, different set of people with individual thoughts, opinions and feelings. With your hair line. But that's obviously a bit different. I don't feel like the Kardashians are. I don't feel like the Kardashians are.
I don't know. Well, if we really want to go there, Gabby Hannah, do you remember her? She got her hairline done. Oh my God, Gabby now! Like years ago, and I didn't even know this was the thing. Who's Gabby Hannah? YouTuber.
YouTube. Like, yeah. She's also, I don't support her either. Anyway. No more problem about it. So, no, it was just one of the thing. So it's like the whole story. I like bleached my hair, like home bleached it in like 2020. And like if you lift up my hair, you can see just like patches of like.
Where the bleach was and the, like, And I'm just very aware of it because I can never wear my hair up in like high ponies anymore Because like I can see it. I just like would love to get little tattoos on it just to like make it look fuller, you know? Because I love my hair. Yeah. And it's just like I just like. Would you ever shave your head?
A hundred percent would love to shave my head. Maybe we'd be talking about this all weekend. Maybe. Maybe I want to shave the head. I do because I'm sick. I've bleached my hair a couple times and I'm just sick of it. Mm-hmm. And then.
You're going to shave it off. Yeah, I want to get rid of it. I was thinking of dyeing it pink, like bleaching it dying at pink because I love pink. She's wearing, okay, sorry for the listeners, she's wearing full pink right now. Pink socks, pink pants, pink top, pink undies. Somewhat. Somewhat pink on these. And a beautiful, a beautiful pink blush.
Oh, you've got a pink scrunching in. Oh my gosh, she's got a pink scrunching in as well. Anyway, but yes, because I feel my hair feels just gross. I'm not happy with it, just personally. Yeah. I saw this thing that was like when you want to change a physical part of your body it's not that you want to change that
it's that you want to change something psychological about yourself you want to change something internally so it was like when you feel the inclination to like shave your head or change your hair not your head change your hair color you know get lip fillers get a nose piercing get a tattoo it's because you're going through a period of change
and you want your outside to represent the internal fundamental change. Well I got my symptom done in the middle of January this year. I got the piercing. I pushed it up because we went swimming, but sorry if this is not. I like got it done and I got it in a period where I felt really out of control in my life and I wanted to take control and I just did it. And it's like I can, I was like, yeah. It was such a, it was such a big moment for me, you know? I feel like this way I got my um first tattoo in January this year and it's just quite, she's not huge but she's like, quite big for a first tattoo. Oh my god it is big for a first tattoo. Yeah, it's sizable.
It's not it's not the biggest but it's issues up there. Um and then I like a couple months later before so interestingly this wasn't a period of change but also I kind of had planned this for a while so it's a bit different but and then I got the ones on my arms when I was leaving Hobart and they're kind of smaller ones I got three kind of smallish ones including some writing and I had such interesting conversations with people back because they were like oh I really love it blah blah blah and I was like thank you so much for affirming this because for the first time ever I felt like I was like old enough and mature enough and responsible enough to make decisions about how I wanted my body to look
wow and it was like and I had some conversations with people are like I would never get a tattoo in my life oh my god and I was like yeah but like I actually like didn't really have any qualms about it because at the end of the day it made me feel so incredibly in control of my body I'm more in touch with my body. I'm very deeply connected to who I am as a person and like my values. This sounds really deep. It's not really that deep, but it kind of is.
Like, my values and like who I am as a person and like the artwork that I like at this stage in life and like everything kind of has a certain meaning because not everybody gets tattoos with meaning but my ones to start with are with meaning because that like is what I want. And it like really, really kind of made me feel in control of my body in a way which I do not always feel.
And now when I look at my body, I'm like, oh, I got to do that. It's mine. This is mine. Like, this is a decision I made because I can do things for myself. Yeah. And I trust myself as well. Like, when you got your tattoo, did you feel that way? Um, I got it on my 18.
Wasn't that deep Meg, tell us. No, I went with my friend. I just turned out in on the day. Oh, you're mountain tattoo? Yeah, yeah. And I just went with my friend. she was going to get a bee but it was too big and we just rang up the local tattoo power in Victoria like where it was living and I was like I'll just get that little
mountain and then it cost me 50 bucks yeah 50 bucks yeah woo do you know my 20 very well price if there's anyone still listening I have a tattoo dedicated to Taylor Swift and that cost me 160 dollars and you know how small it is right yeah where was no no I know oh it was it was it in Sydney it was in Sydney it was in Sydney Well, my was just a local small town. That is quite, I put... It was a really nice place though. And also, I will say this.
So I'm similar to Aaron in that all of my tattoos have very deep and distinct meanings for the period of my life in which I got them. And it's interesting because right now I'm in this period where I'm like, there actually isn't anything that would fully represent this for me. It's actually a good point because like the mountains. I've met a tattoo. No, so all other periods in my life I've been like, oh yeah, if someone asked me to tattoo something on my body, I'd know what I would do. because I know very, very clearly what my values are at the moment, what my kind of guiding thought and principles and life feels like. Like, you know, all my tattoos, like the ones I have on my, on my hips,
on my ribs, the one I have on my back, the one I have on my hip. Yeah. All very, like, things that I really stand by. But right now, I really couldn't tell you. I couldn't, I really couldn't decide how I feel about my life right now. But when I look back at the tattoos I have gotten, especially the one
so I have on my on my right side I have this really beautiful tree and it has an eye in it and I don't think I've told you this before but it means independence because at the time I was feeling
incredibly dependent on people validation I got out of a really quite like abusive toxic relationship and it was like I really needed a reminder of myself of like I'm an independent person I can exist without the validation and the input of these people. And when I look at it, I know exactly how that felt, and I know exactly why I got it.
And the same with, like, some of my other ones as well. Like, I know exactly why I got them. And they're really meaningful to me because of that. But now I'm like, I actually don't know what would really define this period of my life. See, I think I have a lot of, like, art Instagrams. And I follow them. I'm like, that's so pretty. I want that on me forever. Like, I saw a really nice one today as well. And I was going through a page. And I was like, oh, my God, a tattoo ticket is only $60. does. Ooh, look at all the pretty things I could get. But interestingly, they are all at the moment. They're all women. They're all figures of women and they're all naked, mostly. The one of my back's naked. I have a naked woman on my back with like plows and stuff.
And all of the ones I see, I don't know whether it's that. It makes farting. I don't know that it's the artist I follow, but all of them are like naked women. But I think it's like kind of obsession with like the female body and the female figure and like the relationship I have with that myself and how society expects women to look and I think I love the subversion of a lot of artists I follow where it's like actually we don't subscribe to the notion of like having to look I've only ever gotten tattooed by women. E.J. Would you get a tattoo? A hundred percent. I'm definitely definitely getting a tattooed. Do you get it from my friend Sydney? Yeah, 100% I really want one. So shout out to Sydney. She's a friend of the podcast, friend of the show. And she's a tattoo artist
and she is incredibly, incredibly talented and has given me a tattoo before. So She's in Melbourne, if anyone wants it. Sydney Ferry. An incredible, incredible artist. What's her Instagram? Sid Ferry. How do you spell that? S-Y-D-F-A-R-E-Y.
F-A-R-E-I. I feel like they can listen back to it. E-Y. E-Y? Okay. But she's very, very talented. I really want her to give E-J-1. I really want one. So we're 44 minutes in.
Let's do one more question. Okay. What else do we have? What's a question that we really want to ask? Oh, goodness. This is... Okay, let's... Do we want a fun question?
Do you find a reflify? question? I'm going to ask us a question. What do we want? A gem question? A gem question. Okay, let's do that. So we've had some very deep conversations, but we're going to finish off with one final question. Kind of random. But what is the one song that defines your life right now? Oh my God. What do you think it is? If you could pick one song that really encapsulates, these guys have ice cream sandwiches now. You can hear that noise. What's one song that really defines your life right now. I've got to think.
So I actually know what it is. Go. Do you want to go, E.J.? Well, my first song that came in my head was hotel room service by Pitbull. But that is what we've been listening to all weekend. That's true. So I'm like, very happy around my friends and I feel a little love.
So I'm going to say hotel room service. Yeah. You know? It really, it really like capitulates or represents like this experience of having a really beautiful weekend. It is, yeah. Listening to really good music. Yeah. I have one. What is it? It's this song called
by Disco Lines. It's just a song I'm really like in the moment. It's called Baby Girl. Yeah. Beautiful. It's just a scattered song. It's just like chill techno music. It's not really much lyrics. It's just like really nice to listen to. And it's probably, is that in the moment. What's the vibe of the song? Is it a party song? It's very upbeat, like, yeah, yeah, pretty party song.
Like, yeah. It's like, have a good time, but they don't really know what's going on. I would say my song is Better Man by Taylor Swift Because I've been just feeling really sad And really like heartbroken And I think that song really kind of puts you in the place of Um Experiencing that and there's this song that's like You Push My Love Away like it's some kind of loaded gun
And that really It really makes me quite sad Because I think I went through like quite a traumatic experience of like really putting myself out there and being you know very much in love with this person and getting rejected and which is hard and it's really hard and it's made me really sad and like I've really been struggling with it recently but when I listened to that song and like wow if Taylor Swift has experienced this and I'm experiencing this everything about the world just feels a little bit better and Erin what would you say your one song sorry we had a cat emergency oh what happens
No, the cat we're looking after is an outdoor cat. Boo! Yes! Outdoor cats are... No outdoor cats. No outdoor cats. Bad for the environment. But we're looking after her.
And she can tell when we're about to shut her in. And so we can't walk past her in the kitchen to shut the back door because she's got like a little outdoor cat area that has a door that you have to shut. And the cat flap doesn't shut so you can't like shut the cat flap. So anyway. So you have to like go outside to shut the door But if you walk past her in the kitchen She'll run outside
So Jack and I figured out that we could walk around the back of the house To shut the door and you can like walk this giant loop around the house In the dark This is quite a big house And she's figured out what it sounds like When we're walking around the back to shut the door So she runs away So you can't like trap her in the house at night
Which is like really really bad Because cats 100% need to come inside When it gets dark So Jack was like, yeah, don't know what to do. So she escaped. So she escaped, basically. But it's why she's an outdoor cat, so she comes back. But it's just so annoying.
Like, why can't she just? But Erin, what's your song? What's your song represents your life? So mine was Better Man by Taylor Swift. Nakes was Baby Girl by Disco Lines. And EJ's was hotel room service by Pitbull. Okay, wait, let me go through. Oh, me and the hotel room.
You can bring your friend. So I feel like it's really sad because it makes us like this upbeat tempo Oh, I actually have a really nice song that at the moment I'm really liking. Actually, can I have two? Yes, go for it.
Okay. So my first one is something called the Uggam-Bugam song by Brenton Wood. I'm so sad. Mine is so sad. So much joy. Do you want to?
Can I play a short clip? I can't play a shortcut? They have to go out. Can I sing it? Oh. No, I'll play it. Let's see you guys later. It's joyful.
It's pure joy in a song. It's fantastic. And it makes me feel happy every time I hear it. So if you're having a bad day, listen to the Ogum-Buggin' song by Brenton Wood. And it is truly, truly. What's the other one, Aaron? Okay, the other song.
The other song is called To Be in Love with Yourself by Bobby Boyd. Okay, I actually like that. And it's beautiful. It's like, I don't know what era it's from. Let's have a look on Spotify. But we should listen to both of these songs. You should listen to both of these songs because this one is really beautiful. And it's just this guy singing about like, and it literally just goes to be in love with yourself.
Can I read up the lyrics for a little bit? It's okay. So Aaron's on a real self-love journey. It's really... She's also on a real podcast tangent journey in which she needs to read out the lyrics. No, I need to. Okay. Because I need you all to listen to these beautiful words.
We're going to be here for them. You're not. You're not. My first. sliding. Sorry. That is a very beautiful song. You're going to cut the service out.
I'm not going to cut the service out. It's going to be fine. I'm literally Googling things. It's all good. Oh, there's like not even that many lyrics out there because it's quite an old song. So what are the lyrics?
Okay, I'm trying to try to load. We really want to know what the lyrics are. Sonychitz.com. Load my lyrics. Okay, these are absolutely not the right lyrics. Okay, well, how about you just like. But it basically just goes to me in love with yourself. And it's really beautiful.
And the lyrics make me want to cry every time, it's like sometimes it's like hard and sometimes it's easy and he just like sings about all these these things and I think he's singing to a girl about how good it is to be in love with you so because he like sings a girl in the song but yeah okay actually that was a really that was a lot beautiful more beautiful than if we'd heard the lyrics okay no no no really really sweet way I'm glad that you explained it that way yeah well I'd like to thank my beautiful guess oh was that our last question it was no wonder Meg was trying to hurry me along well I would like to thank you guys coming on and um yeah welcome to the first episode of Girl Talks and if you
liked it, subscribe, give us a rating you know the deal. Follow us on Instagram Yeah. I hope you enjoyed it. Did you guys enjoy it? Leave it with you. Yes. Five stars. Please. I hope that you guys will have nothing left. I will. I've rated it at five. I haven't written no video. I didn't realize that you could rate things
on Spotify. You can. Yeah. So Meg better get on it. So that was only a recent thing that you could rate stuff on Spotify. Yeah, it's very recent. So you guys better fucking get on it and thank you for listening and thank you guys for the vulnerable chats. This has been a slightly useful conversation. Who cares if it isn't? We're going to be able to listen back to this.
We'll listen to it, but hopefully you, the listener, have made it to the end and have enjoyed it. I love every time you say thank you for listening to the end because I always listen to the end. Do you listen to the end, E.J.? I do. I can show you. I have true. No, but it's really lovely because whenever you say that, it makes me really happy. Because it's probably just you and E. Because it's probably just me and E.
PJ listening to the end of the episode. My mom doesn't even listen to the end. My mom doesn't have time to listen to my podcast. No, I love your mom. But thank you so much for listening and we'll see you guys next time. Hey, what's good y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hardway with your favorite therapist and host Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere,
but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor? It signals to the world that you're not to be playing. not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to, listen to learn the hard way on the IHard radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcast. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. And on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world.
Put yourself through some hardships. And you will. come out on the other side, a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO percent on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. When a group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist, they take matters into their own hands. I vowed. I will be his last target. He is not going to get away with this.
He's going to get what he deserves. We always say that trust your girlfriends. Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe, on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. This is an IHeart podcast. Guaranteed human. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.